here's how luck and coffee went from
trying to detour Starbucks to being
delisted from the American Stock Market
to many investors lucken's growth
numbers were simply way too good to be
true an anonymous fund manager had been
monitoring luck and coffee for a while
and had already uncovered massive
disparities the fund manager had hired 1
000 investigators to monitor their foot
traffic at lock and locations across
China these investigators also collected
25 000 received from customers to
estimate the average cost of each order
using this data the fund was able to
estimate the quarterly sales of luck in
throughout the third and fourth quarters
of 2019 and the disparity between the
estimated sales and reported sales
wasn't 5 or 10 percent no it was 69 in
the third quarter and 88 in the fourth
quarter it was pretty clear that lucken
was faking sales but the fund manager
didn't want to release evidence himself
as he feared the backlash he would
receive from investors so he asked
Carson to release the report and Carson
would follow through as soon as the
report debuted in February 2020 luck and
coffee plunged